hello everyone
I said hello everyone
all right thanks for coming here uh this
afternoon my name is Jimmy Bogard um you
can find me on Twitter at J Bogard and
this presentation is on my GitHub at
github.com there's a presentations
repository so all the code you see there
from this and all my other presentations
will be there and I blog about this and
all that other stuff on my blog at
jimmyboguard.com
all right
um so this is a this is a fun talk I
like to do because
a lot of teams I talk to meet that are
kind of new to domain-driven design they
think that you know because they have an
existing system or like existing code
base that they can't possibly apply
these domain different design principles
to the code they already have
um they think they need like a fresh
clean slate Greenfield application and
only then can they apply this kind of
drone Wayne driven design principles
but that's absolutely not the case and
so this talk is really about taking a
set of taking a code base that is not
using domain driven design and using
refactoring techniques to slowly
refactor it towards an actual domain
model
but first let's talk about what is uh
domain driven design
um
so the funny thing is that there's not
actually a concise definition in the
original book so I had a kind of glean
one from it
um but it's a architectural design
strategy in which we selectively distill
organize and Abstract the body of
knowledge from the users to the software
users could be you know the product
owners it could be the other like domain
experts or the actual users themselves
there's three kind of important parts of
that this is the distillation so we're
taking the complexities of the real
world and we're not trying to map the
exact like down to the atom things that
happen in the real world or if there's
like processes and stuff we're not
trying to capture every single step so
we're we're being selective about
picking this part and this part in this
part and then
um explicitly modeling those Concepts in
the software that we build
and so a lot of domain driven design
revolves around this idea of an object
model of the domain and that's what a
domain model is this term actually
predates the blue book The Big Blue Book
of domain different design
um it uh the one of the previous
definitions came from Fowler's book the
patterns of Enterprise application
architecture and he described it as an
object model of the domain that
incorporates both behavior and data
and those those two parts are important
if it only had data then it's just a
data model if it only had Behavior then
it's just functions and so the dummy
model in an object-orienting language
needs to incorporate both things in
order to be considered a quote domain
model
yes but my existing code it sucks so how
do we take the code that exists today
and then try to represent our this
domain model uh idea interactional code
base
well one great way of doing this would
be to use test terminal design that has
these three steps of red green refactor
um or most Legacy code bases that I see
with like little to no actual automated
tests it's more just like well we'll run
it in production and then we'll get it's
working okay but we'll have we'll just
refactor right there
so looking at an existing code base
um just figuring out how to refactor
this safely and effectively and also
trying to understand you know what are
we what's our end goal what are we
refacting towards there's a lot of great
literature out there on how to perform
these refactoring since also a lot of
great tooling as well so we'll be
standing on the shoulders of other
Giants of these different refactoring
techniques that I did not make up that
are just already named out there and
actually have nothing to do with the
domain driven design and a few of the
books that I really like
um to to refer back to for these kind of
refactoring techniques the first one is
Michael feather's great book working
effectively with Legacy code
um that's just like how do I make exist
how can I refactor existing Legacy code
safely and add and make it testable as
well
of course there's Martin Fowler's book
which has the second edition now which
covers a lot of refactoring techniques
and then my favorite patterns book is
Joshua karovsky's refactoring to
patterns so all of these look at all
these kind of revolver on the same
concept of I have some existing code
that exhibits some kind of design or
code smells and here are some potential
refactoring techniques to address those
different code smells
Well what we'll be doing is using these
techniques to refactor an existing kind
of procedural set of code towards an
actual domain model
but first let's look at the existing
states of the code as it is today
so I've got here the class diagram of
our our current quote model so one thing
that is nice right now is that the names
of these things do match the names the
like the users use and the business
experts use and the product owners use
so that's one good thing
um I would say if you are in your
existing systems and applications the
names don't match what the business uses
and the names don't match what the users
use that is something to kind of try to
address uh earlier than later to say can
we at least agree upon the names of
things and then make sure the names are
the things in our code also match the
names of things in the real world
so this code base is meant to Model A
loyalty reward system and so in this
loyalty reward system
um you have people in the real world
that can become a member of this loyalty
reward system so right away we've got a
class called member so that's one good
thing so far
it's not called person it's not called
human it's not called
um it's it's called member because it's
not not every single person in the in
the world is is considered a member of
this loyalty reward system so this is
already like a being selective about uh
who uh we represent in the system
the attributes as part of that class
correspond to the things that the
business cares about so the email and
their name
and then it has a relationship over to
this offer class
and an offer that represents an
individual uh like coupon or discount
applied to a a specific member so an
offer is tied directly to a single
member so if I am assigned a a coupon or
an offer and I get it scanned then it's
used and I can't no one else can use it
because it's specific to me
finally we have some administration of
these different kinds of offers and so
we have this offer type class that has
some kind of metadata information about
the different kinds of offers I can
assign
now if I look at the the arrows between
these things um they even represent the
the real relationships between these
different kinds of uh objects so member
doesn't just have an offers property it
has an assigned offers property the
offer cost itself doesn't have just a
member property it has the member signs
so the name of it reflects the
relationship between these two uh
between those two entities
so looking at this though um there's
something missing
which is the behavior these classes only
have properties and have no methods I
mean they have I guess like the equals
method but like that doesn't really
count
um it has no it has no domain Behavior
associated with these with with these
different objects
um so where is the behavior the behavior
does exist somewhere in the system but
where does it exist
well like it could be in the controller
action it could be in the click Handler
it can be in like helper methods or
helper classes or manager classes so
there's probably like a member manager
an offer manager an offer helper so this
thing the behavior does exist in the
system but it's not uh it's not
reflected in those different domain
objects
so in this case I've got a Services
folder that contains all the different
kinds of uh services that represents the
different actions the user can perform
uh related to these different uh related
to these different entities
all right so let's switch over to the
code
so I'll stop sharing here
and
go over to visual studio all right so
from here on out we'll be just in Visual
Studio using again the standard
refactoring techniques to refactor this
existing non-behavioral application to
an actual you know real real domain
model
um now one thing you don't see here is a
tests project that was intentional
because I was lazy and I didn't want to
write tests but in in actuality we
should be writing tests along the way to
make sure that the behaviors we're
adding
um reflect the the behaviors we're
intending
but nothing like that for now
okay so I see down over here in the
services folder there's a few classes
over here and these represent the
different actions the user can perform
I've got an assigned offer Handler so
that represents all the logic associated
with assigning an offer to a member and
the next one I have is the expire offer
Handler so that's the the action that
represents the uh the expiration or
expiring an offer for an individual
member
and so if I look at these I'll just pop
them the assign offer Handler
um so the first thing I'll do when I
look at any kind of class or uh any file
to see like what is this class doing one
of the first things I look at is just
what are the different uh using
statements we have here and so right
away I can see that we've got it's using
the services namespace here so that's
where the kind of DB context comes comes
into play it's got Json stuff so Json
and HTTP so there must be some API web
AP web API calls being made here it's
got threading because we are
everything's async these days so that's
always going to be there and it's also
using mediator this is that about that
library but the uh it's also using that
to represent an individual action
now this class takes a couple
dependencies so we can already see that
it's using dependency injection and
inside its uh Constructor dependencies
we can see that it takes an app DB
context so it must be doing some Entity
framework junk and it takes an HTTP
client so it must be calling out to
these web some web API web apis
all right so let's look Lex at the uh
the handle method
okay so um it looks like the very first
thing it does is it loads some data out
of the database from from any framework
that's like most of the actions in an
application the first thing that happens
is loading up some data and then I see
some code comments so it looks like
right away someone thought this code was
too complex so let's add some code code
comments to make it less complex right
so it looks like the first step is then
to calculate the offer value and it
looks like it's using a uh a web API to
do so so make some API call to calculate
offer value passing in the member's
email and the offer type so those two
things like maybe there's some maybe
there's some like calculations behind
the scenes to say oh if you're a good
member then you get a higher discount or
maybe it's like uh maybe if you if you
um you have more points or something you
can get a bigger discount as well
so it makes the API call make sure I got
a successful status code and then gets
the value of right after doing this
deserialization
all right next up we have is calculating
the expiration date so it looks like
just a switch statement that's saying uh
depending on the offer expiration type
we're going to calculate the expiration
date based on either if it's an
assignment type it'll add days to today
to say this is to give it an expiration
date so it'll look at the days valid so
if it's valid for 10 days or 15 days
it'll just add 10 days from today and
that's the that's the date it expires
and the effects type will just say
adding days to the begin date so the
offer begins like maybe it begins on May
1st and it's good for the entire month
of May so that it ends on May 30th
30 days May yes
and the final component is is the actual
you know kind of real work being done in
this method is to assign an offer to a
method all right sign an offer to a
member so it creates the offer object
and then adds the offer to the assigned
offers list on the member object and
then looks like here there are some
calculated fields in this application
maybe there's like a little summary
widget at the top of the page or maybe
they do some reporting to sum up the
number of active offers so it looks like
it's pre-calculating this this number of
active offers based on whenever someone
modifies the assigned offers
finally it will
add the offer to the offers DB sets so
Entity framework junk and then finally
save changes
now looking at this method it's not like
terrible if some of my team wrote this I
would probably you know be okay with the
pull request but uh that would be like a
very short presentation so I think we
can do better so let's look and see what
different ways we can uh what different
techniques we can use to refactor this
code
um so the first thing I'm looking at is
I've got code comments describing
sections of code so one of the first
things we can do is to Simply extract
methods for each one of those blocks of
things happening so that I have a better
idea of like what that block of code is
doing what are the different parameters
it's using what data is it using uh what
date does it read and what data does it
write so I'll just go here and say
extract method
yes
and the name of the method uh let's see
well the code comment said calculate
offer value so that seems like a pretty
good name for method so calculate offer
value
it's telling me that it takes two
parameters the member in the offer type
those seem okay to me and so I will give
it a name of
calculate offer value
all right we'll do the same thing for
the next uh set of code here that's been
commented out so extraction method here
and say calculate expiration dates
extract method calculate
expiration date
and then finally assign offer
uh sign
offer
all right so that looks a little bit
better now it reads more like a story I
guess I've got the initial part that's
loading the data I've got the first
method that calculates the offer value
I've got this next method to calculates
the expiration dates and finally the the
last method that we'll assign the offer
to the member
so this refactoring that I just did Here
is known as the compose method
refactoring the composed method retap
refactoring takes a long method and
breaks it up into a series of smaller
methods in which each of those smaller
methods has the same level of complexity
or the same level of granularity so I
don't have like one method that's broken
into like 16 methods I just have like
one method for kind of each of the main
major steps that happen in this in this
code
um and this this met this overall handle
method right now
um is actually using uh another pattern
from the Fowler book for patterns of
Enterprise application architecture this
is known as the transaction script
pattern transaction script pattern is
just this idea that I have individual
actions for the different things that
are happening in my application and each
of those different actions is
represented by a single method that does
all the work that is uh that is then
wrapped in a transaction so this is
wrapped into transaction I've got the
save changes and the like the implicit
uh transaction of Entity Framework
and then it just contains all the logic
and a sort of procedural way right here
now again
um if I saw this in a pull request I
still might accept it and say well
that's clean enough for me I can read
the different steps in each of these and
I want to see and if I want to see the
details behind them I can go to the
individual methods and look for the
details there
but again that would be a very short
presentation and not very fun so let's
keep going
so the next thing I'll do
is look at each of these individual
methods look at what logic is inside of
there and try to figure out should that
logic belong somewhere else
so let's get the first one calculate
offer value
all right so this method
the first thing I see
is that it's
not static it's an instance method and
that what what that Clues me into is
that because the services or the
dependencies of this class are also
instance Fields because it did not
refactor into a static method that means
that it's using those dependencies in
some way and sure enough we see right
here it is using this HTTP client
dependency
now looking at this right here if I
wanted to add a test to test out this
logic and behavior well this is going to
be a problem right it's calling out to
some web service and as the code exists
right now it is more difficult to sort
of mock or fake that fake that call out
so what I'd like to do instead is
refactor this method and extract it into
a separate class
and by the way I am using resharper here
and that's uh I I don't get any like
kickbacks from them or anything like
that I've just been using vershopper for
like ever so it's just a bit easier for
me to use those tools and the other
thing that is a bit different for me
sharper there are going to be some
refactoring techniques I'll show you
that don't exist in any other like free
tool that you could use whether it's
rosin extensions or anything like that
and I'll highlight those when I get to
them but those are the ones that I
leverage a more powerful tool in order
to be able to do those more interesting
refactorings so
let's then extract this and I'm going to
and extract a class
and so we're going to extract a class
and first we have to give it to first we
have to give it a name and this one says
uh
it's it's it's the method name is
calculate offer value and so if I want
to turn that into kind of a name of
something that uh or the name of the
responsibility of this I could call it
the offer value calculator let's call it
that offer value calculator
it has a little red here and says uh and
it needs to figure out how to get this
HTTP client dependency and so I'm going
to tell it to do is uh let's see I can
give it that uh object as its own
dependency so I've moved that field from
The Source class to the target class
the next thing it says is uh I need to
make this method public because it's
private right now so let's go ahead and
do that
I'll click next leave it in the same
file and let's see what happened
so we see that method just disappeared
here it's gone and where put it is over
here at the top of this file
so here we have now an offer value
calculator with a dependency on an HTTP
client
and then the behavior of this is the
exact Behavior we saw before so it does
the VAR response that goes blah blah
blah call the API uh DCR is the read the
content deserialize the content and then
return the value so exact same thing it
did before just bloop extract it into a
class and put it in the same file here
foreign
my my uh my initial class we can see
that uh this
um is instantiating now the offer value
calculator directly inside of this
Constructor here
so we're still not at our testable
States so if we want to get to a
testable State we'll have to have an
interface for this in order to be able
to mock it out in our unit tests
the unit tests that don't exist
so again I'm going to put my little
carrot on top of this calculate offer
Value method I'm going to say
extract interface
and now it's going to offer an it's
going to tell me a name it's going to
give it a name of I offer value
calculator that seems that seems
reasonable and it's going to ask which
members and want to extract and so just
that one sounds good
hit next
and now we have an I offer value
calculator interface with this single
implementation of the offer value
calculator
now I don't like the name of that class
I don't like implementations of an
interface that just dropped the I that
doesn't give me any hint or clue about
how this class implements that interface
or what it's doing behind the scenes so
we're going to rename this class to web
service
offer value calculator
we won't rename the related symbols
because who cares and there we go
all right so now we have a web service
offer value calculator that implements
this interface now because I've got uh
oh we'll get there in a second here okay
so back over here I still don't have a a
testable interface here so I will put my
little carrot over here and said uh
refactor this and down here there's a
use base type where possible
so what this is doing is saying I'm
using a more derived type if I look at
all the usages of this type can I use
the base type instead and so what I
wanted to do is to examine all those use
cases and say am I using the the class
methods or am I using the interface
methods and this is a safe way for us to
then perform that refactoring
so use base type where possible and then
not system.object that would be silly
the interface
and then there we go it just changed
that into an interface versus the type
now I could have done that myself right
I could have just
hit backspace backspace backspace
backspace and then I and then see if it
compiled but by using the tool it's a
little bit a little bit a little bit
smarter and and more intelligent about
analyzing the usages of it and so it's a
safer uh it's a safer change versus just
kind of manually editing the code
all right the last thing I want to do is
it's still not unattestable because it
just directly puts in this HTTP client
so I'm going to say I want to refactor
this and I want to introduce a parameter
for this thing
that is the I offer value calculator and
it also tells me this parameter can be
safely removed so let's do that remove
the HTTP client parameter and now I just
have the offer value calculator
next
okay now this is a warning because we're
using dependency injection and there are
no unit tests that it says there are no
usages of this new Constructor that
you're telling me to do and so you'll
probably have to go fix that somehow so
just giving me a little warning here
I hit next and then
oops it did not do that right initialize
field there we go
it was not exactly perfect all the time
so we have to fix up a little things no
big deal
okay so we introduced this interface we
well first we extracted the method into
its own class so that is the uh extract
it's the extract method into class
refactoring
um we introduced an inter we introduced
an interface for that one method we
modified all of our usages in this class
to use the interface instead of the
instance instead of the derived type and
the very last thing we need to do is fix
up the dependency injection junk because
something has to inject this dependency
that is going to be the DI container so
over here on let's see start up
services
dot add HTTP clients it'll be the I
offer offer value calculator and the
drive type is going to be the web
service offer value calculator
and then the
I would then inside of here need to give
it the uh the the URL to wherever that
is but we this is all made up and make
believe so there's no URL there
okay
so what we've introduced here though is
a domain service so this service does
some domain calculation and it's
interacting with our with our domain
model in order to perform this
calculation but if I looked at that
method to understand like where should
this logic belong
the way I'll determine that is to look
at this method and say what are the
primary objects that it's interacting
with
and so if I look at this method I'll
first look at the first parameter say
what is using this
and I just see that well it's really
just
the pulling out the email property here
but that's about it it's not interacting
with anything else on that member object
what about offer type
it's only this offer type dot name
property that it's accessing over here
so if I'm looking at this method and
trying to figure out where should this
logic and behavior go it could either go
in
the member object the offer type object
probably not the cancellation token
again that's that's silly or just some
other class and because this method is
not primarily dealing with just one of
these objects it's just like it's
dealing with both of them equally then
neither of those are a good candidate
for where this logic should belong and
also it's like it's primarily just
calling a web service so because it
doesn't doesn't
primarily deal with any of those um
either the domain objects those entities
then extracting this out into its own
class is the next best thing
okay
so so far we have we haven't really
refactored anything into a domain model
although domain services are part of the
model so that's not exactly true
um but so I mean it's not it's still not
exactly that interesting
so looking at these next two methods
um at this point I'm like I I don't know
where all this logic should belong so
maybe let's apply some defactoring to
put the logic back into this method so
we can see it see the bigger picture
now I do this all the time I don't just
refactor my code I also defactor my code
so if I'm even trying to understand a
new code base for the first time and
it's it's very heavily very heavily
factored one of the first things I'll do
is defactor that to put all the logic
back into one place to see what's going
on and then I'll hit uh you know git
reset and then put it back to where it
was before
so let's do that here
um let's defactor these two methods so
I'll go to this one and I'll say uh
inline this method
inline all usages yes
um it didn't understand how to do the
state expiring thing so I'm going to
just inline that as well
let's see let's refactor this
and say let's inline
that variable
and then rename this to date expiring
the way it was before
okay so I defactored that method let's
defactor the second method
Ctrl alt n to inline the method and get
it back to it was before
same kind of issue we saw earlier and
that it has uh it is it is uh preserve
that variable reference for whatever
reason and so I'm going to inline this
again
I could ask the jet brings people why it
does this but again I'm lazy about
things like that all right so now we've
kind of kind of got things back to where
they were before of all the logic except
for this external dependency is now back
in this one single method and I used I
like to use this technique a lot just to
like kind of take a step back and say
okay what is this what is all this stuff
doing
um to try to see kind of the uh the
force for the trees that is
well one of the first things that I can
see here is that it's got a little like
a little green line under there telling
me that it can simplify the switch
statement and so I'm on a newer version
of C sharp and so it can actually uh
change that to a switch expression
so that already looks a bit better
um and so now I've got uh this
calculating the expiration dates and the
signing of the offer
so looking at each of these this uh this
expiration one first
if I'm looking at that set of code I'm
looking at where uh where is a good
place for this kind of logic to belong
and looking at this logic
I can extract that method again just to
see what it looks like
and I can see that it is just taking the
offer type as an input and having the
date expiration as an output and the
method itself is static which means
there are no dependencies so that could
tell me that a good place for this logic
could be on this offer type object
itself
so let's do that I'm going to refactor
this method first let's change the name
calculate
expiration expiration date
and we Factor this to move this to
another type
now I'm going to cheat here though
because there's an even more powerful
refactoring technique than this one way
down here there's another refactoring
refactoring option here to say make this
method non-static
now that's refactoring we'll look and
see that this method is static and so if
I want to make the method non-static
then that method needs to belong to some
instance
and so when I do this method refactoring
it's going to ask me okay if I'm going
to make it non-static what instance
parameter do you want to move this
method to
and the input is the offer type object
and so I'm going to go ahead and say Yes
make that method non-static and move it
over to the offer type object itself
so now over here I've got a calculate
expiration date method but notice it no
longer uses the like it doesn't go offer
type dot expiration expiration type
instead what it's doing is it converted
all those usages of calling into the
object's properties and instead replaces
them with the instance properties
so that is pretty neat
I'm actually going to inline that and
make this an expression bodied
statements because why not
now if I looked at this as well and
saying well where else could this logic
possibly belong I could say well
it's kind of equally dealing with the
offer type objects and the expiration
type object however expiration type
is an enum and enums are just fancy ants
they don't get behavior and so sometimes
what I'll do is create a class around
this enumeration and like Java has these
they have a new enum classes but that
can be a bit of a pain for like
persistence uh scenarios and things like
that so I'm just going to leave it alone
and say you know even though this that
set of logic may be better in here and
and the expiration type enum because
it's not a class I can't move that
behavior over there
all right so let's go back over to the
assign offer Handler and so I've got
this date expiring
and then I have the assigning the offer
so I'm going to do the same thing again
I'm going to extract
this into a method with the intent of
seeing what are the inputs and what are
the outputs
so extract a method call it assign offer
and again we see wait a second this
method is static so it means that this
method is not using any dependencies in
this uh this Handler class that's a good
thing that means that I can move it
somewhere else without worrying about
having the dependencies having to come
along for the ride
so I'll do the same thing we did with
the last one which is to look at the
usages of each of these values and try
to figure out is there a good are one of
these a good candidate to move this
method into
so let's go one by one I've got the
member parameter so looking at usages
looks like I got one two three usages of
member
looking at offer type
just one usage down here which is
sending the property
and then finally int value I mean we
don't own that type we're probably not
going to move Behavior into the in class
even though they might let us do that
with their new c-sharp 11 stuff
um but you know that's not a very good
candidate so we're just going to leave
that alone
and then the same thing about date
expiring it's just that by itself
so I'm going to refactor this
and making making this method non-static
because member seemed like had the most
stuff going on uh let's go ahead and
extract this method and move it into the
member um into the member object
so what's going to happen though is
everywhere you see member
it's going to either put this or just
take it off so right here it'll be
replaced with this and then these two
usages down here it will just remove
them
so I'll go next
away goes the method and then over on
our member object
now we see
here's our sign offer method taking in
the offer type taking in the value and
taking in the date expiring
now going back to my Handler class I
kind of thought it was a bit strange
that this calculate expiration date was
outside of the assign offer method and
the other thing that's kind of weird is
that this date expiring is derived from
the offer type
so right now this assign offer method
it's parameters say give me an offer
type give me the value and also give me
the data it expires so this could be
like date time dot max value could be
daytime.min value it could be yesterday
so it's not kind of fully encapsulating
the logic of how should it calculate the
expiration date does that belong to the
member object to know for itself like I
I know how to uh I know how to calculate
the expiration date or who to rely on I
don't want you to just give me any
expiration date that's my responsibility
so undo
put the date expiring back
all right so what we're going to do is
in this assign offer method I'm going to
inline this parameter and inlining the
parameter we'll look for all the usages
of someone calling into that method and
then offer those as potential candidates
for using that as a value instead
now this had like a thousand usages I
may be like oh that's that's too many
maybe this this class doesn't have that
responsibility because there's too much
variability but if I look for usages of
this because we have no unit tests
um there's just this one single usage in
my application
so I'm going to refactor this parameter
I'm going to say inline this parameter
it's going to use
this date time from date expiring
and it's going to get rid of this date
expiring
now hit next
and here we go
oops
that didn't do what I wanted
control alt and inline that CS parameter
removed don't add that parameter there
we go
okay and so this one now instead of
being date expiring instead that should
be offer type
dot calculate expiration date
it's a note over my usage of the offer
Handler I no longer need this calculate
expiration date so I can go ahead and
get rid of that
now there's another way of doing this if
I go back over to member and I could
undo
and put this back on there
um I can go back over to my object over
here and I can say let's go ahead and
inline this parameter
and so just passes that in right there
and now when I go ahead and inline this
parameter here
inline parameter
there we go
that's a that's what I wanted to do the
first time but I forgot to inline the
first the first one over there okay so
it saw that the one usage I had in here
was me passing through that value and so
it says okay I'll go ahead and use that
value as or use that expression as the
thing I'm going to use to calculate the
expiration date
so
I think I can actually get rid of some
code comments now because they're not
really not really adding anything of
value here so let's go to that and get
rid of that
okay so now what I have is a single call
out to that interface to calculate the
offer value and then a single call over
to my domain object to then actually
assign the offer to the menu to the
member based on that value that I
calculated earlier
so this I think is pretty good right now
because it's got most of the behavior of
assigning the offer inside the actual
domain object itself and it's it's fully
encapsulated that entire operation
now one thing we could do and I'll try
it and I think about half of you will
hate it so uh that's fine it's been
perfectly fine is
um if I look at this member object now
it's still being it's still being able
to get any kind of value being passed in
and so it's still not telling the caller
of this that you know you can't just
pass me any value you need you need to
give me an offer value calculator
because that is really the thing I need
to use in order to calculate this offer
value I don't want you to just be able
to do whatever you want
so if you want to do that refactoring
I will inline this value
now it has a weight calculate offer
value in there and if I go to the assign
offer method I can also then inline this
value as well
it will add these two parameters the
offer value calculator and a
cancellation token
and now this needs to be an async task
of offer
because it has to await the calculation
of that offer value
so now we've got VAR offer equals member
to sign offer but I actually need to
await this over here as well so I'll say
await member data sign offer and now
instead of us passing through just any
old value what it's doing is saying you
need to give me an offer value
calculator and that's the thing I need
to use in order to calculate the offer
value not just any value that you want
to pass in through there
and so now that's it's made this uh it's
made that dependency explicit saying uh
me as a domain object I rely on this
other domain service in order to perform
my work but because we don't have
dependency injection that's okay we'll
just pass in the dependency as a as a
method parameter and so this code is
still unit testable it still doesn't
have any code dependencies on external
external uh Services because it's that
interface
the only wonky thing about this is that
it's got async and a domain model and
that's usually where like half the
people will kind of like feel sick and
want to throw up because like async and
a domain model that seems kind of odd
um but in any case this pattern is known
as the double dispatch pattern the
double dispatch pattern is often used in
domain models where perhaps the logic of
Performing this business logic is pretty
complex and so I want to I want to put
that business logic inside of the domain
model but there's just like one or two
little Parts what has to reach out into
some are external service and then
perhaps there's some interplay between
the business logic and calling things
whatever and so this provides a nice way
of still preserving this encapsulated
domain model but being able to pass
through dependencies
um still look behind the interface as
method parameters
um are you getting like half my teams
like this about half the teams
absolutely hate it
um so I just want to throw it up there
as like it's a possibility but if your
team doesn't like it that's fine just
passing the value like we did earlier no
big deal
all right
so at this point it is like
fully refactored from a transaction
script put and I've now pushed all of my
behavior down into this domain object
however much you may not like that one
part
we're not done yet
I've been looking at my domain model
it lets people do a lot more things than
it should allow so if I wanted to do
something like
member.assignedoffers.clear
that would give the product owners a
conniption fit that would freak out
because we're like you can't just clear
out someone's offers because some of
them are still good and they'll complain
and you know they'll go try to use some
coupon and it says offer not valid
anymore but nothing in our domain model
makes That explicit or clear that you
can't you shouldn't be able to do this
but the API does let us do this
we can also do things like VAR member
two equals new member and then we just
don't have to give it anything
so if I went to the business and said
okay um so I got this member object it's
got these three these four parameters
um but those those parameters those
properties don't have any values is that
okay again they would not be okay with
that because like for them there are
some critical pieces of information that
make this object a quote member versus
just like any any other objects or any
other person walking off the street
so I go up to them and ask them like
what are the things that if you took any
one of these things away it would no
longer be that thing and you kind of
think it's like
um what makes a zebra a zebra if you
take the stripes away from a zebra is it
still a zebra
I guess if there's stripless zebras
maybe I don't know
um but it would be like a horse I guess
um I suppose the same kind of thing that
I look at each of these properties and
say which of these properties are
absolutely required for this to be a
thing and if I took any one of those
away it would no longer be that thing
and those are known as invariants and
variants are the things that if I took
anything away it would no longer be that
thing
it's also known as like these business
rules that are always held to be true
and so we need we need we need to
preserve them so they go over to the
member object
so the problem is that it's just got a
public nowhere Constructor generated by
the um generated by the compiler and
lets anyone create anything and set
absolutely anything anytime they want so
let's fix that
let's create a Constructor
then it comes that includes those
invariants which are the first name the
last name and the email
uh finish
and now it has set those individual
properties
now there's some other problems with
this code because if I go over to the
member object let's not do that I can
still do something like member.firstname
equals null
and that again is not something the
business probably wants us to do and so
I'd want to go through those different
operations and say okay what are the use
cases that we have for changing this
information and then let's make those
use cases explicit as individual methods
so what I'd like to do instead is say
you know private sets don't let anyone
access this private sets
private sets
um we asked the business is it okay for
them to change this information and they
say yes they can change their first name
they can change their last name but they
can't change their email I just made
that up let's just pretend that's the
case
so now what I want to do is create a
method that allows someone to to change
their first name and last name so I'm
going to create a method that says
public
void change name and they can pass in
the first name first name and last name
and as part of that we're going to set
the first name and last name property
nope I thought I'd just do it
automatically for me that would have
been nice first name equals first name
and then last name
equals last name
and then if we were on the very new
newest version of C sharp we could do
something like a bang bang operator I
think and it would do the argument null
exception thing we're not yet so or if
that even is going to make it in the in
the feature or in the next version of C
sharp so what I want to do here is is
check to see if these are no more empty
oh look at that tab if strings are null
are empty throw oh look at that
very smart tab
yes
yes
okay
by the way that is the Microsoft code
assist the AI service that will like do
that magic for you it's kind of like the
GitHub the GitHub thing as well
um no I'm not playing but I just saw
that it came up like oh that's that's
exactly what I want thank you
now I have encapsulated the operation of
changing the this uh changing the name
of this member and it's now enforcing
those invariants and saying if you don't
if you give me blank or null names I'm
not going to allow them I'm going to
throw an exception
now there probably is a screen behind
this that allows a member to change
their name so I still expect that screen
to have that sort of validation and so
this is just kind of the last resort
that says I'm going to protect my uh my
Aggregates and variants by making sure
that those invariants are always
enforced
okay
um let's go let's go over here and the
other thing we were looking at was the
member could just clear off the the list
of offers and so we don't want anyone to
just be able to do anything to that list
so what I'd like to do instead is
encapsulate those collections so instead
of having this like public list of
assigned offers
instead what I like to do is say I will
only expose out the operations that I I
I will allow you to perform and nothing
else
so look at this
Target type new there we go
okay so the way we can we can examine
this is I can just I can refactor on the
list type and say use base type where
possible and I'm going to want it to I
want to select the most protected kind
of bass type and for me that could
either be a read-only collection maybe
there's some stuff there or just I
enumerable
um let's go with maybe read-only list or
inumerable maybe just iron numerable
let's just do that
um however nothing happened that's
because it couldn't perform that
refactoring something else is still
using that list so if I go over here and
say let's go ahead and make this let's
cheat I innumerable of offer okay and
now this needs to be go back to what it
was before a new list of offer and the
next thing we want to do though is we
want to uh we want to let's see over
here
two property with backing field
get assigned offers set assign offers
and probably make this a private set
because we don't want people just do
whatever they want
okay so by making that's a private field
it means that down here I can't just go
off the list of assigned the public
property anymore I gotta go to the
private field and now
this should be a
list
of offer there we go
and this right here I think we just want
to get rid of this we don't want to
allow anyone to set it so just be a get
only proper a get only property
now depending on your orm of choice this
may not be possible I'm pretty sure EF
core allows you to do this of having a
backing field with a uh with a with the
actual type it needs to be in this case
a list but it's something you want to
check to see is that is that possible
and you may have to kind of mold or
shape how this is getting encapsulated
based on what is actually possible and
your orm of choice if this thing if this
object is is what gets persisted
directly with your RM
okay so we cheated
this code compiles and if I compile the
whole colbase
I did not put on the turbo button to
make this go fast oh build succeeded
wait a second that's not that's not
correct
because if I go over to my other Handler
here
laptop members assigned offers a single
default oh I forgot the other one yes
okay
there's another one I wanted to uh to
fix here which was over my signed offer
Handler I could do something like
member dot assign number of active
offers equals in.max value you get all
the offers all of them
but that doesn't make a lot of sense
notice neither does having a negative
value there either so the problem is I'm
still allowing anyone to be able to
change this value uh so what I'd like to
do is go over to the number of active
offers property
and make this Setter private I've made
the other Setters private but I haven't
fixed this one so let's go ahead and fix
this one so I can put a little private
there
this code
still succeeds
now if I compile oh there we go that's
what I was looking for
the property or indexer of number of
active offers cannot be used in this
context because the setter is
inaccessible
so sad trombone
okay that's not something we uh that's
that's not insurmountable so what I'd
like to do is do the same refactoring to
this method that we just previously did
on the last method which is to extract
first look at this class and see what is
it doing
it looks like it's also using that
transaction script pattern so it's it's
loading up some data performing some
operations on that data and then saving
the data all in one single method
so I probably won't extract methods for
the getting of the data and the saving
of the data that's not very interesting
this is the actual interesting part the
middle
so if I extract that method
and let's see what is this doing this is
expire offer Handler so this is probably
going to be expire offer
next all right so it's still not
compiling but that's okay we're going to
put this in the right place to make sure
that it can't actually access that
property
um one other thing here it's it's it's
using this request object
um I don't necessarily want to uh use
that as a candidate for
um where this Behavior should lie so if
I'm looking at each of these objects it
says
um each of the parameter inputs has got
this request object and remember but
that request object is kind of throwing
me off here so let's actually go over to
uh this request offer ID I'm going to
introduce a parameter for that
replace two occurrences
with offer ID and it's also telling me
that it can safely remove this request
object as a parameter because that is
just not using it anymore
so click next
and now if I go back up I can see what's
being passed in is passing in the
request.offer ID and then down here it's
now just a guide
so again let's look to see which one of
these objects should I now pass the or
now extract this logic into
should it go into one of the input
parameters one of the other objects
that's being used in here or another
class entirely
so if you look at the usages of each of
these parameters
I see three usages of the member object
I see one usage of offer ID but again
that's a that's a that's a one of our
primitive types so that's not a
candidate for us to move that logic to
but another valid one we could look at
is this offer object down here
I see two usages of that
so
three of the member I think
oh nope just two so two the offer to the
member but it looks like it's using
Member First it uses member to go and
find the offer it's interested in so
let's go ahead and extract or
move make this method non-static and
move it to the member method that was a
mouthful
sorry Factor Make method non-static
select the instance parameter member
next
aha so now this this this transaction
script method is now nice and clean load
the data delegate to The Domain model
and then save the data
now if I go look at my expire offer
method
uh it's compiling again because now it
can actually uh now I could actually
mutate the number of active offers
because it's a private Setter and I can
access it private Setter from this
instance method
all right nope we don't want that hahaha
all right so where do we uh where are we
going up here so we get this assign
offer method that takes
um it takes the offer value calculator
and the offer type oh but here's another
one of those problems where it's got
just a bunch of things that are publicly
sets and I can't um I won't be able to
actually use those uh so this would be
another candidate for us to look at how
can we encapsulate the creation of this
offer object
and again it's just got a bunch of
Public public Setters so what I'd like
to do is talk to the business and ask
them okay
um which one of these can I take away
and it would no longer be an offer
and looking at these they need all four
of those properties if they took away
the member an offer is not uh an offer
unless it's assigned to a member that's
that's kind of a requirement for the
system I do need to know what the type
of the offer is in order to have other
logic Associated I have to have an
expiration date we don't have offers
that can expire at the heat death of the
universe and there has to be a value for
that offer as well so all of these
things
so let's create a Constructor
that includes all of those different
values
oh check parameters for null sure
all right and now we can make all of
these Setters private private
private
two privates
two private
I can also make those and it only and it
only properties there are some issues
with that so I'm just going to leave it
alone I still prefer private Setters for
domain models
now I do also ask the business can you
change any of these values once an offer
has been assigned and they say no you
cannot change anything I cannot reassign
offers I cannot change the type of the
offer I cannot change the expiration
date I can only create new offers that
have a new expiration date I can't do
anything with the old ones
actually that's not true I can expire
hey guys let's go back over to
okay so this code no longer compiles and
so I'm going to need to
call that Constructor with all the
different values so I've got members
signed is now this right there offer
type
and then the await thing I'm now
regretting that
our value there we go
that was the expiration date so that's
the offer type dot calculate expiration
dates
and then finally the value
all right and now I can get rid of all
of that
all right so I passed in the parameter
for this offer type offer type that
calculation calculate expiration date
that looks a bit odd it's passing the
offer type and then also kind of calling
another method immediately so let's fix
that I'll go over here and I'm going to
inline that parameter
the date expiring and then next
and now let's replace that usage with
the one place that found calling it type
that calculate expiration dates I will
leave the value alone because you can't
have async Constructors and it would be
too painful to like try to push that
down so let's just not do that and so
now over here I've got get the calculate
the offer value and same to the offer
with those different values and then
then it's done so now at this point my
invariants are now enforced on the offer
object itself that it's not allowing you
to change any of these after the object
has been created
oh but there's some red down here oh you
can change the expiration date so yeah
that was another feature that the
business needed is that if they
accidentally assigned too many offers to
people or someone did like some
fraudulent thing they would expire the
offer which just would set the
expiration date today date today so you
couldn't use it anymore
so we actually need to
um
extract a method
expire
and this should not be a questiony one
that should be
uh
just regular one there we go
and then what we'll do is refactor this
to make this method non-static moving it
over to the offer object and now it just
says offer dot expire
so at this point my domain model the
offer entity now fully encapsulates any
Behavior associated with the date
expiring
so
our initial transaction script methods
had all the logic associated with the
domain inside of that single method and
what we've done is use these standard
code smells and standard refractoring
techniques to refactor this code but
with a with a with a goal with a
direction in mind we're trying to
refactor this towards a domain model and
so what I'm doing is preferring moving
these methods into the domain models
itself as opposed to other helper
manager whatever classes
and really that's that's kind of the big
difference between like
um like object oriented code that is
still like not using domain models that
behavior exists in your application
somewhere but it's just not inside of
those objects and and domain driven
design is is about uh having those
behavioral models that enforce their own
invariance they enforce their own
business rules as by having those domain
models and force on their own business
rules we ensure that these domain models
don't get quote invalid at any point in
time
all right I think I feel pretty good
about this do y'all feel okay about this
maybe minus this right there
yeah that's fine
all right
um so that was going back to my
presentation
that was domain driven refactoring we
pushed our Behavior into our domain
model using the standard refactoring
techniques that have been well
documented well before
um you know like long many many years
ago even decades ago now uh and so if
you have a code base
that it has maybe all the names of
things aren't quite there
um but your behavior scattered across
your whole application these techniques
can help you build a domain model uh by
just using these kind of regular
standard refactoring techniques
so thank you very much if you have any
questions about this I'll be hanging
around afterwards or you can find me on
slack otherwise have a great rest of the
conference and uh yeah thanks
[Applause]